Kylie Jenner isn't letting her split
from Travis Scott affect the family but
they want to know real personal stuff
that like makes me a little
uncomfortable to share
a source tells E.T Kylie is solely
focused on her kids and work right now
previously a source confirmed that the
beauty Mogul and the rapper are on a
break Kai and Trav share two children
together a five-year-old daughter stormy
and a one-year-old son air and ET sour
says Kylie is trying to stay positive
doing her own thing and wants to keep
things cordial with Travis for the sake
of their family she wants things to be
balanced and remain drama-free so I'm
really happy about that and in true
Kardashian Jenner fashion E.T Source
says Kylie is centering her energy
around work and spending as much time as
she can with family and friends I'm very
passionate about Kylie cosmetics and
just making sure everything is perfect
for you guys going over things a hundred
times back in January A source told E.T
that the on-again off-again couple was
on a break the two have had an up and
down relationship and although they
aren't together right now it doesn't
mean it's over for good The Source
explained that they live different
Lifestyles and that's been a big issue
with two kids Kylie doesn't go out too
much Travis on the other hand lives a
life of late nights in the studio and
going out with friends Kylie and Travis
were first Linked In 2017. after a brief
split in 2019 they revved things back up
in 2020 and had been together ever since
the passage to my daughter imma show
What it Took baby mama cover fours got
these other shook back in August Kylie
shared these loved up snaps on Instagram
alongside the caption Utopia with you
but just two months later Instagram
model rojin Carr posted this video where
she claimed she and Trav were hooking up
behind Kylie's back you had every single
girl I know blowing me up like trav's
asking for you to come back you cheat on
every single night the whole city sees
it
don't do this Travis denied all that on
his insta story writing quote I don't
know this person I've never been with
this person so please stop with the
continuous cyber games and the fictional
storytelling and while Kylie and Travis
may be on a break now
ET Source says the two love and respect
each other and will continue to
co-parent
foreign